et je dois dire que c'est justement la
lah avec poiret vous êtes parti dans un
monde qui est un monde de fantaisie et
vous jouer ça depuis 700 représentations
jouit
je sais que très souvent les gens te
disent mais ça doit être fatiguant de
jouer 700 fois toujours la même chose
battus chez moi je connais des gens
aient enfin j'ai des confrères par
exemple qui sont fatigués la 30e
comprend un moment de lassitude à
répondre et même mois ça peut arriver à
la 50e de ne pas avoir envie soit
vraiment jouer mais autrement on doit
tous les soirs il se passe quelque chose
de nouveau il ya la salle d'abord il ya
notre humeur notre humeur à nous il ya
l'humeur du comédien qui n'est jamais
jamais là même où on est fatigué ou on
est en forme où on est gay mon actrice
enfin de là il ya un tas de choses comme
ça donc jamais la même représentation
c'est pas vrai et les gens changent
quand on frappe les trois coups quand ça
se fait mais moi je suis pas moi je sais
jamais ce qui va se passer
et puis tant mieux enfin je dirais je ne
sais jamais mais malin si tu veux si je
pousse salle à l'extrême je ne sais pas
ce que jean dame dire bien sûr parce que
j'essaie de découvrir les choses
la minute à la seconde à vue mais en
même temps que le spectateur
ah bah oui pas ça c'est bien sûr
naturellement de ce congrès il faut
suivre la pièce études et découvrir les
choses vont jamais précédé le spectateur
sinon c'est foutu